All too often
I see procedural fairness letters for misrepresentation
issues in the immigration.
Misrepresentation is a serious offence in Canadian
immigration
and can get you banned for 5 years from the country.
Here are top 3 ways to avoid this misrepresentation
finding. One is that you have to make sure that you
tell the truth on all of your applications.
It seems fairly obvious,
but including past refusals
or any past criminality issues is crucial
on your applications.
If not, RCC may issue you a misrepresentation warning.
Second is that
you have to make sure that all of the information
declared on your applications match.
So if you've prepared an application
before for maybe a study permit or a visitor visa
and now you're playing for permanent residency,
you want to make sure that the information is the same
or else the immigration officer
might say that you lied on one of your applications
and therefore
you may face a misrepresentation ban.
Third is that you have to declare
all changes in marital or family composition.
This is one of the biggest issues I see
where someone doesn't declare that they got married
or that they got divorced
or that they had a child
and then IRCC finds out after the fact
and then they are
banned for misrepresentation
as a result of this emission.
Remember, misrepresentation can arise from either a
will fill misrepresentation
meaning that you meant to lie to them
or an innocent misrepresentation
meaning that You accidentally
forgot to include the information,
but it will still get you the same penalty,
which is a five year ban from Canada
due to misrepresentation.
If you have any questions about misrepresentation
or making sure that you don't face any penalties
when it comes to misrepresentation,
please get in touch.
We have lots of experience with these types of cases.